et
[Musique]
lady stark quel bon ben vous amène
l'hiver est là il m'est arrivé pas mal
de merde
certes oui c'est peu de le dire donc je
voulais voir s'il allait m'arriver
quelque chose de sympa où là c'est pas
prévu ça commença alors je suis pas
censé vous dire mais je crains pour vous
ce soit la même compote tout vote d'hier
je pourrais changer mon état civil
comment ça on peut également envoyer un
corbeau apparemment je suis un bâtard
maintenant je suis john targaryen donc
ça veut dire chut nabeul je vais pouvoir
officiellement me marier avec dalé neri
ce vote tentent fait maintenant c'est
fait on peut pas se marier pour moi
c'est un peu particulier
je suis amoureux d'une femme catherine
et stark d'accord donc tout le monde est
au courant
ouais ok donc oui catherine et je suis
tellement amoureux d'elle je suis
tellement obsédé par elle tuer j'en suis
attiré par sa soeur
je ne sais pas trop et sa fille a
annoncé moi n'importe quoi par exemple
que quelqu'un me dise à tes souhaits ou
que je réussisse une omelette place et
c'est marrant ça je les ai bommel est là
mais non vous allez la rater c'était une
trois champions d'ailleurs la cat vous
êtes un gardien dan ellis sera ta ta ta
ta ta ta ineris est allé targaryen oui
puisque ces matins du coup ça veut dire
que vous pouvez pécho voilà alors plus
et même la tradition de la famille non
oui je viens de croiser john snow dans
les couloirs là apparemment il aurait le
droit de choper sa tante [ __ ] moi ça
fait des années qu'on pète les rouleaux
sous prétexte qu'avec ma soeur on aime
bien se faire des bisous dans les fesses
de temps en temps est lui déjà à la
basse et 1 bat à 1
et maintenant on apprend c'est le neveu
de l'art et de légitimer en plus il a
droit de la pécho basséen prague à rien
en plus le cas il a le charisme d'une
sacoche je viens de croiser john snow
c'est vrai qu'il va [ __ ] sa tante
ouais ouais parce que nous la garde de
nuit ses ceintures pas de sexe la vie
est injuste mon petit bonhomme qu'est ce
que voulez que je vous dise je suis tout
seul comme un con
bien bien seul imaginez comment c'est
chiant 12 mois al alam
pardon je pars entendre c'est pour pour
se braquer est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
nick et là c'est le moment je pense non
non non c'est pas prévu
personne ne nie que sur le mur même une
de nos tentes
c'est grâce pour stop merci vous pouvez
sortir chaud parce que là je bande l'a
déjà très tard et nevis de typhons de la
maison targaryen première du nom rennes
de mary oui oui bon c'est bon pas la
peine de fayoter vise à riom mon
troisième dragons qui est tombée aux
mains des marcheurs de l'anglais
justement parlons-en
donc moi pour avoir mais dragon j'ai
fait une fausse couche gênons brûler
dans les flammes du bûcher de mon mari
je me suis retrouvé à poils à poil je
n'étais pas dans les steppes au cul du
monde et lula le lightning fait groupe
sur une île mon visa riom et c'est plié
je comprends
j'imagine que vous êtes là parce que
vous avez tout gâché que vous avez fait
des pires choix que même jamie vous a
laissé tomber je cherche la can
la cave à vins du pic rade de l'agneau
du rouge du plan cap mathis est rien il
n'y a pas ici avec des vieux bouquins de
la poussière des araignées trop bout de
caillou mais ces derniers temps jure
choses ont dû être réglé de manière
assez rapide et peut-être des petits
morceaux qu'on était un peu bâclé quoi
c'est de la merde de merde oui non je
n'en je dirais plutôt torche et c'est de
la merde c'est glam et un an les
diamondbacks il est le paquet je dirais
peut-être que vous avez une attirance
plus pour les pour les rousses le frère
de katyn par exemple vous en foutez ce
soir à qui a du charisme à me dois je
m'en fous on sent rassuré quand on est à
côté lui ai donc c'est pas rien quoi ça
faisait envie de se rapprocher de vie
physiquement quoi vous êtes amoureux de
lui pourquoi les firmes pas loin d'être
des chevaliers je sais pas parce que
chevalière c'est un genre de blague
c'est par un argument ça non c'est un
jeune veau et sinon il ya une vraie
raison de la guerre c'est un truc de
mecs c'est un truc viril quoi les femmes
sont des frêles créatures sakifo a les
idées moyenâgeuses square bah je sais
pas jorah mormont tout à fait mérité
vous une minute à m'accorder s'il vous
plaît en fait j'ai écrit une petite
lettre d'amour et j'aimerais bien avoir
votre avis moi je suis pas là pour ça
mais j'avais des six chaires d'amneris
c'est mort si je peux être un truc sympa
à un moment il va y avoir un petit coup
de vent et vous allez être interné il va
y avoir de la mort sentir de l'amour
certains gags ya plein femmes qui
voudraient pouvoir aller à la guerre non
mon avis non il ya vous est peut-être si
l'autre grand blond de la comptine c'est
pas vrai ya plein de gens qui pensent
comme moi même des hommes
bon bah quand tu aura plein d'autres
gens qui veulent la même chose que vous
j'y repenserai je remercie
babbitt oui et j'en ai plus celui passé
moi aussi je veux que les filles
puissent être chevalier
je ne suis pas du moi aussi je veux
qualifié puisse être chevalier
moi aussi j'aimerais que les filles
puissent être chevalier moi aussi
j'aimerais que les filles puissent être
chevalier
moi aussi je veux que les femmes
puissent devenir chose à faire là bas
mais c'est grillé c'est ma tête la bombe
regarde mais on va pas passer la journée
là dessus là je me suis vanné voulais
pas qu'ils aient bertha non la beauce eu
aucune tâche deux heures avec un pied
bot qui vont des poulardes vous l'aimez
pas reine elle a vendu des poulardes à
katyn je crois une fois j'aime je laime
la souplesse ou non avec votre verges
dedans oui en érection
j'imagine déjà pas me faire jeter
entraîné ni la mienne d'ailleurs voulait
tester c'est l'effroi où ces fonds il ya
une pathologie catherine stark
si je vous dis que c'est moi par exemple
ok stop
je suis juste me pour élaguer tapas du
shit bon est ce film ta plume là tout
seul quand on aurait vraiment rire
vézien voix et les blue je les aime tous
l'admettons ça c'est dan ellis
ouais et la tête à tête intérêts moi je
pourrais très bien ça c'est vous ouais
vous êtes là à vie pour toujours
c'est loin loin c'est quoi les chaînes
assez il faudrait une autre carte hockey
j'ai vu dans les plaines glacées du nord
s'est levé une sombre menace contre
toute forme de vie de la corneille
jusqu'à la rose doré du cr majestueux à
la truite vivace tous vont se réunir au
son du flûtiau céleste
des volutes de fumée purpurines
embaumeront les pupilles et c'est les
narines
dans une ultime célébration de la vie ok
c'est ça que je veux